recently I did a video discussing my
theory on what caused the disasters in
the new Netflix original film how it
ends I summarized that the cataclysm was
due to a volcanic eruption from one of
the two super volcanoes that exists
within America and this explained how
the airplane had been down and how there
were ash clouds littering the landscape
however since then I've came across
another highly likely theory for this
disasters and throughout this video I'll
be discussing my alternative theory on
what caused the events there will be
heavy spoilers for how it ends so if you
don't want to know how it ends then you
need to turn off this video because all
I do is talk about how it I'll stop now
without the way I'm definition and this
is my alternative theory for how it ends
on their journey we'll and Tom encounter
all means of electrical phenomena from
spinning compasses too erratic birds and
electrical storms after looking up the
possible causes of this it's clear that
these events were caused by a shift in
the Earth's poles many times over our
planets history Earth's magnetic poles
have reversed meaning that sometimes a
compass pointing north will be aimed at
Antarctica rather than the Arctic this
might sound strange but it's a
relatively predictable quirk of the
planet
powered by the mechanizations of the
planet spinning iron core this process
of geometric reversal has been doing its
thing without much fanfare for eons as
birds use Earth's magnetic field to
navigate we can clearly see in how it
ends that their flight pattern has been
thrown off to to the reveal traversing
the aurora borealis appearing on their
adventure to shows that there's
something wrong with the Earth's
geography and this definitely cements
that something is hot in terms of
magnetism I still believe that super
volcanoes had a huge part to play in the
disaster however this was likely a
byproduct of the magnetic field turning
and it's possible that the two
earth-shattering events were one of the
same don't worry though whilst it's
never a ball that the poles
eventually shift scientists estimate
that it's not just an overnight
occurrence and when such an event does
happen it will take place over thousands
of years so chances are you won't even
notice
unless it's happening right now it's not
as dramatic as how the N makes it out to
be
you won't suddenly wake up and find that
your granddad's u uncle and your
grandma's your sister and Santa's
workshops in the southern hemisphere and
the only major noticeable effect that's
guaranteed to occur when the Polar flop
is finished is that your compass needle
will point in the opposite direction
this will make things like where I'm
from in the Northeast not really true in
the southwest will become so North look
I don't know it's really difficult
discussing movies ending when the movie
doesn't even have an ending why is it
called how it ends anyway what did you
think of the film are you sick of
blacklisted Netflix original films
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create videos
like this weekly and will definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film make sure you check
out my original explanation of how it
ends linked at the end of this one and
thanks very much for taking the time to
watch this video take care peace
you